welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on the unlimited
strength and power you can unlock inside
of yourself by rejecting the light and
turning to the all-encompassing dark
magic it's what i did that's why i'm so
magical all the time my name is mt and
i'm here today with off-screen producer
brandon what's going on brandon hello mt
i guess if if you practice the dart
magic i have to be your foil on the
light side and try it try and bring you
back bring you back to the goodness
even though dark magic is so much better
it's so much cooler so much fun
it's going to be like day man versus
night man you know i'll be night man you
could be babe man david
fighter of the night man
all right brandon hit me with our big
question brandon okay mt we finally got
the moon night trailer it came out this
week hey beautiful uh and it seems like
marvel is continuing to dive deeper and
deeper into the dark magical arts that
exist within the mcu it seems to be part
of this new you know multiverse era of
the mcu it's going to bring in a lot
more dark magic where's severus snape
when you need him yeah right where is he
at we need that dark magic but like so
now we got all these like players in the
dark magic game but like who are they
and how do they stack up against each
other it all leads us to this week's big
question who are the most powerful dark
magic users in the
mcu ooh
that is a great question brad and well
let's go through all the different
wielders of dark magic in the mcu and
see who comes out on top and let's start
off with everyone's favorite suburban
mom who mind controls the whole entire
neighborhood wanda maximoff that's not
being a very good neighbor but hey
if you control the neighborhood then you
get to decide who's the good neighbor
yeah that's right that's right
you'll always win the like uh the
christmas lights contest for the
neighborhood if you control the
neighborhood exactly the scarlet witch
yes she is technically a practitioner of
chaos magic however now that she
possesses the darkhold she's definitely
looking into the powers of dark magic
and actually i think that chaos magic is
actually dark magic which is why wanda
is in the dark hold in the first place
and remember agatha harkness said that
scarlet witch was prophesied to be even
more powerful than the sorcerer's
supreme and she's a mom so
she's already more powerful than the
sort of supreme bear that's right but
mom's ruled the world i can barely walk
and breathe at the same time so moms be
walking breathing driving the kids to
soccer practice uh performing heart
surgery you guys are amazing i don't
know how you guys do it my mom performed
heart surgery on me and i'm a better man
for it exactly you're gonna live forever
honestly
yes wanda is a mom that wants to find
her interdimensional children out there
somewhere in the multiverse and she's
willing to use any kind of magic at her
disposal to get that done so i don't see
why she wouldn't use that dark chaos
energy magic that has searched inside of
her ever since those hydra experiments
yeah i think you're right empty like
that makes sense that chaos magic it's
it's probably closer to dark magic on
the magic spectrum than like eldritch
magic which is maybe on more the light
side and i think one has like the great
excuse of like i don't know what i'm
doing i'm just moving my hands it's like
she studied it it was like she says i'm
just doing magic i didn't know it was
dark magic sorry everybody but now that
she knows she ain't got to stop i mean
she's got a little taste of how powerful
it can be she has the book now she has
the dark magic encyclopedia now that she
she can purposely ruin lives rather than
accidentally so yeah right and i think i
think she's got a good reason you know
she's been uh used and abused by more
powerful people uh everywhere from hydra
to the avengers like you know throwing
her in jail
i mean a pretty nice jail you know you
get to have power cash and everything
martha stewart jail
in jail uh pretty nice compound but um
yeah i think i think she's got she's got
her reasons and you know now that she
knows that she
has kids or manifested kids or that
there's a version of her with kids she
wants to find them she wants them back
uh so everybody better get out of her
way get the creep out of her way because
she's coming for you but of course next
up we got the queen of dark magic
herself we gotta talk about agatha
harkness baby because she is the
greatest woman that ever existed in the
mcu in my opinion she killed her mom
which is not the best thing to say after
i said that she killed her
that's why that's why mt loves her
full stop into the conversation thanks
everybody see you next week empty is a
mother hater no mothers
and she killed her mom and the entire
book club when she was just a young
witch and now she's mind prisoned in the
suburb but we know that that's not going
to last forever i mean it'd be really
terrible if it did especially because
she has her own series on the horizon
house of harkness and she's been
practicing dark magic for hundreds of
years and certainly learned a lot from
the dark hole before rwanda snatched it
from her in a very rude fashion but even
though she's down right now you can't
count her out for too long because
agatha won't stay down she won't she's
she's gotta be back on the back on the
board before you know it and yeah she's
super powerful like hundreds of years of
practicing dark magic existing in the
shadows manipulating uh wills as she
will uh but you know someone's gonna
break her out of there and use her or
she's gonna break out herself like she's
too powerful to be held down and in the
comics i mean she's such a powerful
figure i i i can't see how she doesn't
come back and and really be one of the
strongest dark magic users in the mcu
and hey judging by the name of her show
house of harkness i can see that like
her having siblings because she has a
mom and so she's definitely gonna
probably have siblings they're just like
hey i got that yeah you messed up i'm
gonna break you out you idiot
uh i think there's one thing you don't
do it's tell agatha that she messed up
uh because she'll do it you don't she'll
she'll suck away all your powers 110
but hey if agatha is the queen of dark
magic then this purple face bro is
definitely the king yes i'm talking
about the floating head in space
dormammu he presides over the dark
dimension which is you know a pretty
dark place full of dark energy and
consumes worlds as he sees fit and in
the mcu dark magic uses energy that is
channeled from the dark dimension that
is how the ancient one was able to live
so long and become so ancient but with
amazing skin for an ancient person so is
dormammu destined to come back and
dominate with his dark magic most
definitely like he's gonna he'll be back
soon though i don't know if we'll see
him anytime soon because you know he got
in a whole like logic prison
trick with doctor strange and
you would think he'd very quickly be
like wait i i'm gonna go back and take
take earth but to him like quickly could
be like thousands of years you know
there's tons of other worlds for him to
consume so i don't know how fast he
would be coming back but maybe if he
sees like the defenses are down
he could show up sooner rather than
later but do you think we'll see him
again soon um well we've gotta because
dormammu is such a huge doctor strange
villain it's basically his arch nemesis
in a way on a cosmic scale i mean other
than your your immortals and whatever
but uh yeah i think that dormammu is
definitely the huge threat to the mcu in
waiting and uh once that pinky promised
prison is uh
is down and ready to go he's gonna come
back and try to eat our planet because
there's something about our earth that
he really really wants and like you
gotta think about it he's been munching
on so many multiverses and that's all he
does 24 7. so if he really wants our
earth there's something there that like
we have that he does not have yeah which
is kind of uh crazy yeah i mean he seems
like the perfect villain to come back in
like a doctor strange three maybe i
don't know it seems like going with like
kang
on the horizon right now it seems like
bringing back to her mamamoo now might
be a bit much but i i don't know maybe
kang will use dormammu i don't know but
the fact that like most dark magic in in
like the mcu channels out of the dark
dimension he might he might show up just
because he's like why are all these
people sucking away my my dark magic
powers
and not becoming a mindless one and
floating around in my my space i gotta
go see what's going on with this earth i
gotta show back all these people sucking
me off
get out of here
who's who's drinking my milkshake you
drink my milkshake
my milkshake brings all the boys to the
yard
i suck all these boys in my yard get out
of here get all these boys out of my
yard
and their life is better than yours
you're damn right it's better than yours
but we should also consider the dark
magic using version of doctor strange
that we saw in the what if series this
strange supreme is a version of steven
strange that spent centuries in the lost
library of cagliostro absorbing the
powers of magical beings from different
dimensions including those with dark
magic powers they became incredibly
powerful and in the end almost destroyed
the multiverse which is you know
whoopsies
we'll do anything for live we of course
last left him guarding the pocket
dimension that contained killmonger and
ultravision zola battling for the
infinity stones but it looks like stream
supreme could be returning in a
multiverse of madness could so i do
suspect that this could be just another
alternate evil strange that
you have to remember that doctor strange
has a crazy amount of curiosity across
the multiverse so there's definitely
going to be so many versions of doctor
strange that fall into darkness and
maybe come across the dark hole before
wanda does right and has the darkhold
corrupt their mind so
um maybe this doctor strange and
multiverse of madness isn't strange
supreme but
we can't not we can't discount the
possibility i guess yeah because they
you know when what if was out they made
that statement that like well some of
these characters might transition into
the real world it seems like they were
mainly doing it for captain carter but
it is strange strange to show that
character in the trailer after we just
learned about the what if series and you
just said we're gonna bring people over
and you show us this and he's like kind
of the same but at the end of what if he
was like kind of being good i don't know
it's very confusing but i like that idea
mtv
it makes me think that because steven
strange is so curious and so consumed
with being the most powerful and the
most smart and the most right that in
the multiverse it wouldn't be awesome or
not awesome or interesting if most dr
strange's are evil and like really the
one in the mcu and the one in like earth
616 are good but most of them turn out
evil like that that's an interesting
little twist like we have we have the
perky ones the the ones who stay on the
good side yeah no i think that that's
exactly what this uh doctor strange
movie is going to do in multiverse of
madness it's going to be like all right
yeah more our murderer thinks that
doctor strange is bad but like he could
be a lot worse on the multiversal scale
yeah trust and believe and like since
we're getting of course kang and the
introduction of the council of kangs and
we're we're probably gonna get a council
of reeds i think that we're going to see
um you know different uh groups of
variants sort of like interacting on a
multiversal scale so we saw kang and now
we're going to see how doctor strange
affects the multiversal scale and it's
not going to be great because uh
there's probably just a couple of really
not great doctor strange evil
people out there that want to destroy
the multiverse on purpose or maybe even
by accident because of their curiosity
right because uh doctor strange is
manipulating the time stone too much too
much
manipulation of the time zone yeah you
know all about that mt it's true but
yeah if this is whatever this is a
multiverse of madness we'll find out but
the fact that there is a strange supreme
out there who spent centuries absorbing
uh the powers of other dimensional
beings some of them uh certainly dark
magic and absorbing their powers uses
that dark magic uh this could be why
dormammu shows back up and he's like
wait what's going on he was there
was an evil doctor strange the one dr
strange made was telling me i'm the bad
guy and now there's this guy right
imagine like dormammu makes friends with
this doctor strange he's like hey you're
pretty good i like you i like you
you're you're on the right track i'm on
your side buddy let's go [ __ ] up this
doctor strange that's too nice but hey
now we come to moon knight which will
introduce konju the mythical being that
imbues mark spector with his moon knight
powers and in the comics we learn from
null that konchu is an elder god
predating earth itself he's just sort of
become part of egyptian mythology and we
don't know yet how he'll be represented
in the mcu but like most gods that we've
seen so far he'll probably be pretty
powerful he has superhuman strength
healing durability and is pretty much
immortal and he wields magic and
mystical energies and in the comics has
even absorbed the powers of other heroes
which is pretty diesel and even though
he gave mark spector the moon knight
powers he's pretty much an antagonist
for mark since kanchu pretty much wants
to use mark to unleash vengeance on
earth which is not the greatest thing
yeah i mean earth kind of deserves it uh
we're due for a little vengeance yeah
yeah i mean i don't know yeah on a
universal scale earth has been doing a
little bit too much uh like snapping
yeah yeah two snaps um all this weird
stuff with captain marvel i don't know
what's going on over there earth is
certainly punching above its weight
right now uh in the mcu some of these
like elder gods and the celestials
they're ready to be like okay earth calm
down
you found a toy a little too early
you're not mature enough to handle it
like okay dirt circles calm down
it'll be interesting to see how they
kind of represent khan shu i think in
the mcu because you know when it was
introduced in the 80s it was more of
like oh you're going to be the left hand
of kanchu and do the the goodness on
earth the fist of konchi yeah yeah
you're going to be nice and and make
things right and then later on they kind
of made it more where like conscious was
like yeah you're gonna you're gonna go
people up and mark was like i don't know
this is a crazy idea i'm going through
my own stuff right now and he's like go
do it you gotta do it just do it do it
kill it do it do it it seems like for
this version they're gonna lean more
towards that like kanchu is the
antagonist to mark even though he's like
here's these powers but also i need you
to do this and he's like i don't wanna
it's too much it's too much
i mean we do see him briefly in the
trailer sort of chasing after mark in
the elevator yeah um until he turned
into an old lady
so yeah i think that he might end up
being like this antagonist this like
person that's just like come on mark you
know you want to punch people and kill
people all day mark type of um guy yeah
yeah it would be really cool if kanchu
was like trying to get mark to get to
the ebony blade which was like recently
introduced in eternals
you know all these museums now i'm like
that are in london it's like they're
very close to each other i would love it
if like that was like part of this story
i was like i need you to go get this
ebony blade and mark's like i got a lot
of that i need to go see my therapist
he's like do it go do it
the therapist can wait marks
think mark think i got a question for
umt as we talk about like these dark
magic wielders what about like mordo
we know that you know he used aldrich
magic and he was pissed that the ancient
one was using dark magic but now that
he's out there killing sorcerers or at
least taking away their powers he's
taking their legs away is taking their
legs away this is my magic it's my power
is he using dark magic now or is he
still using like aldrich magic in a in a
a mean way
i think this uh in the case of bordeaux
i think that this is just a mean case of
eldritch magic because mordo even though
he's sort of going in this evil path
he's very much on the side of light and
he wants to defend earth and he wants
people to be safe and he's all about the
protection of the natural law and what
doctor strange was doing in doctor
strange one and what the ancient one was
doing is that they were violating the
natural law by manipulating the time
stone and the dark um dimension energies
respectively so i don't think that mordo
will be a dark magic user he's i think
he's very much against darkness yeah i
think that he actually will be hunting
wanda if anything because she is too
powerful with dark magic but yeah i
don't think that mordo uh will be a dark
magic user just an evil light magic user
okay i like that i like that what about
like the dweller in darkness is he using
like dark magic or is he just using the
magic of the souls that he's he's
sucking in i don't think the dweller in
darkness is a dark magic user i just
think that he is dark by nature i think
that he comes from a dark place like a
dark universe like you know your derma
he uses his dark nature to suck the
light like you know darkness sucks light
in real life absorbs so he's just he's
just a sucker like agatha is he just
wants to suck all the energy out of
people but yeah i think that the dollar
in darkness is just a a dark being that
wants to just absorb the light in
general that makes sense
i like it all right brandon so let's do
our rankings of like who's the top dog
dark magic users in the mcu
who do you think what would your ranking
be uh i mean i would put it like at the
tippy top at the very top i think you
got to put dormammu because he's got
like the whole he's really he's of the
dark dimension he's like super powerful
and he's also like he's a big enough
power that he was not there all the time
like he's not someone you have to
constantly worry about kind of like a
celestial it's like when he shows up
it's a big deal but like he's not an
everyday threat and then like right
beneath him i think you got to put
almost on the same level like strange
supreme and wanda
you know i think the scarlet witch and
strange supreme are like right beneath
him and they're probably pretty much
equal i say that just because wanda's
still new to it and she's still learning
it she's got the ability but she doesn't
have the like the technical skills yet
she's still working that out but like
strange supreme he's had like centuries
to work it out and he knows what he's
doing and he's got a lot of power i
think you put those two right beneath
dormammu and then agatha slips in
underneath them i think you know i would
100 percent agree with that that seems
like it's a very solid ranking because
dormammu is a multiversal creature and
he's darkness on a multiversal level
whereas wanda is only uh you know
darkness on a universal level or in our
universe on the mcu so dormammu has to
be the top dog here because he just has
too much power right where do you think
kanchu is going to fit in on the list
hmm
i would say that khan shu would probably
fit in probably slightly below wanda
okay because he does need a uh an avatar
and he can't move um freely as an entity
so i would say that wanda in a straight
supreme would be a little bit more
powerful than your conscious okay yeah
yeah we'll see we shall see indeed but
have you checked out
newrockstarsmerch.com lately it's got
our awesome book of boba fett shirt
design the hunter it's part of our
latest obsession limited edition series
the spider-man no way home shirt is
already sold out so grab the hunter
quick because you know you guys are
really really loving our shirts and
they're really selling out really quick
so just grab it quickly and while you
still can over at
newrockstarsmerge.com and before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help bring us
a question to you people like
masterclass this is a great time to
invest in yourself and learn something
new with masterclass you can learn from
the world's best minds anytime anywhere
and at your own pace you can learn
science from bill nye improve your
cooking skills with gordon ramsay or
learn how to rap with nas i'm learning
how to rap with nas myself with over 100
classes from a range of world-class
instructors that thing you've always
wanted to do is closer than you think
and here at new rockstars we really
enjoyed the filmmaking and writing
courses the spike lee bob iger and aaron
sorkin classes were all really
interesting and jane foster herself
natalie portman has a cool class on
acting she doesn't really give any tips
on how to wield mjolnir but maybe
they'll add that in later after thor 11
thunder comes out who knows and all the
master classes are really well shot and
edited it's like watching a movie than a
lecture honestly and we highly recommend
that you check it out get unlimited
access to every master class and as a
big question fan you get 15 off an
annual membership go to masterclass.com
big question now that's masterclass.com
bigquestion for percent off masterclass
if saving more and spending less is a
goal for 2022 you should stop paying
insane amounts of money for wireless
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year as the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only mint mobile lets you
maximize your savings with plans
starting at just 15 dollars a month here
at new rockstars multiple staff members
have switched to mobile and they love it
they got to keep their phones and their
numbers and they're saving a bunch of
money boom bada boom by going online
only and eliminating the traditional
cost of retail mint mobile passes
significant savings to you all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network with mint
mobile choose the amount of monthly data
that's right for you and stop paying for
data that you never use switch to mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the phone shipped to
your door for free go to metmobile.com
big q that's mintmobile.com
big q cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
big q
and min mobile is owned by deadpool so
that's you should just do it for that
reason too there you go
how meta all right brandon now it is
time for our bite size questions
brandon i got a question for you
speaking of dark magic and you know all
this oh yeah dark magic stuff going on
in the world is severus snape the only
death eater able to cast a patronus
charm but that is from i aj smith 24 on
discord thank you so much aj smith thank
you yes severus snape you know love him
or hate him i think everyone loves them
i don't think anyone hates them fame
isn't everything he's the only death
eater undercover or otherwise that we
see cast a full patronus in the harry
potter book series and in the films if
you don't know a patronus it's a
powerful and complicated defensive charm
that produces a positive energy force
that often takes the form of an animal
spirit guardian of the caster these
animal shapes are the corporeal form of
the spell and can carry messages and
they're mostly used to defeat the
dementors there are incorporeal
patronuses that are most famously used
by remus lupin to hide his identity but
no one cares about those because they
don't take the shape of a cute little
animal you know snape's patronus is of
course a doe you know a female deer ray
a block of golden sun and it's the same
patronus that harry's mother lily would
conjure because snape was in love with
lily she's the happy memory that snape
uses to summon the ethereal creature
because you have to have that happy
memory inside of you to summon a
patronus charm you got to be a simp like
snake you got to be a synth you got
something for the ladies or a sim for
the men to cast that patronus because
that's the crucial part of the
complicated spell they don't teach the
patronuses in school so if you're
thinking well all the death eaters they
went through school they should know how
to do it they don't teach it in school
kids harry learns it in his third year
from from remus because he's being
tormented by the dementors and then he
goes on to teach it to other members of
dumbledore's army but it's not like a
standard spell that you're going to have
on the newts that you have to be able to
do so
very few wizards are able to cast a full
patronus charm i did the tests on on
like online i got a like a stoat was my
animal it's like a no it's a weasel oh
man that's something i forget what mine
was i did take the test but i forget
what it was yeah i wanted some something
something baller and said i'm i'm on
patronus saying a stoat get out of here
stokes the goats man
stones mcgoats
so
we only ever see snape use a patronus no
other death eaters or any dark wizards
for that matter but is he the only one
able to do it well the author herself
had confirmed in a web chat in 2007 that
he's the only one that can do it
she said because the patronus is used
against the things that the death eaters
generally generate or fight alongside
they would not need patronuses wow i
can't believe that's good we'll take
time out of her day to say that quote
because we all know that she wrote the
harry potter series and no one else yes
i don't know who wrote the harry potter
books i refuse to look into it so
basically what she's saying is that
because the death eaters they use the
dementors they fight alongside them they
have no need for patronus charms also
being a death eater is pretty hard life
pretty dark so you might not have a good
memory inside of you to be able to cast
the patronus i mean it would be cool to
see some like dark patronuses that were
like vultures or other evil animals not
stoats that's
dark stone
not not the dark stones the weasels will
come and get you but snape is the only
death eater that can cast a patronus
full stop hmm okay
interesting i didn't know i had no idea
so this is news for me thank you brandon
there you go but i've got another
question for you don't don't rest up
just yet i'm on my toes i'm ready stay
on them toes because what is the average
speed of a bantha at full gallop and
this is from mj in santa fe on discord
thank you yes yes thank you i couldn't
find anything official on the galloping
speed of evantha i know you're
disappointed there's a lot of other
stats out there for example they have an
average height of 2.5 meters a little
over eight feet just like mt
and they weigh almost 9 000 pounds these
are big big boys out there
there's also if you didn't know this
there's also different species of bantha
the bantha we know is like the common
bantha but there's dune banthas they're
a little skinnier there's timothy shalom
anthony timothy
they're swamp fantas and there's even a
species of bantha native to kashyyyk i
don't know how that monkey dances but
there's wookiee pandas maybe someone
brought one over but it says native to
kashyyyk so i don't know maybe they
brought them to a band i don't know how
they got around the neighbors but
apparently george never got around to
figuring out just how fast they could
run so i started to think about like
real world animals that we could compare
it to and the easiest one that came to
mind was an elephant of course but in
fact when you go back to the filming of
the first star wars a new hope they
actually used an elephant in a costume
to play the bantha it was a female
cosplaying it was a cosplaying elephant
it was a female asian elephant named
margie i believe margie is how you
pronounce it
oh my god yeah and there's all these
cute photos of her putting on her
costume and her trainer bob speicher was
dressed in the tuscan raider outfit and
he's the tuscan we see riding margie
it's her trainer very cute
but all animals should be free and in
the wild and not trained to do tricks
how hard you say you had to hit him
fairly hard so if if we compare a
a bantha to the asian elephant that
played a bantha you know asian elephants
have a top speed of about 15 miles per
hour and their relatives the african
elephants they can reach a top speed of
25 miles per hour which is pretty fast
for a big animal yeah so i would say a
banta is probably somewhere in the 15 to
25 miles per hour range pretty fast i
don't know how much distance they can do
animals don't really run for distance
but if you get going at a full gallop
it's it's got a pretty good top speed i
would say that is pretty
fast for a large creature like that
that's actually quite terrifying i think
a human i think a human average is
around like 10 miles an hour when we get
going so it's like the elephant will run
you down dog you better run that that
will easily just run right through you
yeah yeah like oh my and i had no idea
about margie i know i guess as a kid i
always thought it was a puppet or
something but it was an elephant and a
costume
listen star wars i want
no more of this margie eraser i erase
her i want a dedication for margie she
she put in work okay in a new hope well
thank you brandon that was very
informative indeed as always but now it
is time for the box to scrap boxes
that's just craps now
if dark magic is the most evil end of
the magic spectrum what is some slightly
evil gray magic that you perform in
everyday life on a daily basis oh my my
little bit like my little bit of evil
magic i do yeah a little evilness that
you do i think for me i think for me my
most evil magic that i perform is when
i'm in the elevator in my apartment
building and i hear someone coming and i
quickly press the door close button to
try and keep them from getting on the
elevator with me obviously i do that now
because i don't want to spread
coronavirus but i even did it before
there was a virus i was liz
100 that's my gray magic is i i will
close the elevator doors on you i will
not wait for you i got places to be oh
my that's a good one because i've been
doing that too sometimes let's be real
sometimes people be talking like oh my
god nice day how's the weather like
get out of here i know this is my
elevator what about umt what's your
what's your grey magic that you perform
hmm
i would say my piece of dark magic or
graveyard rather
um is that i i'm i'm one because of like
i have massive anxiety about like
responding to tests right away i am one
to like read the text preview and then
not reply for a while because i'm just
like i i can't respond right now i'm
like ready i don't know you fully read
it yeah okay like sometimes i want to
read something and then like process my
thoughts and then reply but because i'm
an idiot i forget and so i just forget
that they ever texted me it was like oh
no you just you haven't gotten a reply
and there's days later and i'm just like
oh [ __ ] they think that i hate them and
it's too late so i guess i'm screwed
some truly truly evil gray magic mt i'm
proud of you
all my friends hate me
[Laughter]
but that is it for this episode of the
big question i want to thank brandon of
course as always for joining me this
episode he is the highlight of big
question in my heart in my opinion
anyway please follow him at
grindenberric he's the best follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] and theories and
all that stuff but most importantly
follow the new rockstars here on youtube
and on all social media platforms and
make sure you hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video because we do that
pretty much every day and make sure to
find us on discord so you can continue
the new rockstars conversation there
just make sure that you're 18 years old
and older and of course make sure to hit
up the rockstarsmerch.com you get a cool
shirt like superman with an infinity
gauntlet because we'll be making cool
shirts all day long all day but anyway
again thank you guys so much for
watching we love you guys so much
genuinely we'll see you guys next time
goodbye bye
[Music]
happy night man
david
i can barely walk and breathe at the
same time where all these people sucking
me off
get out of here
who's drinking my milkshake you drink my
milkshake i suck all these boys in my
yard get out of here get all these boys
out of my yard you're damn right it's
better than yours all my friends hate me
we can't have any dogs because she keeps
sacrificing them but
but but
she's a bad man she's banging
uh the greatest woman that ever existed
in the mcu in my opinion she killed her
mom which is not the best thing to say
after i said that she killed her
that's why that's why mt loves her
full stop into the conversation thanks
everybody see you next week empty is a
mother hater no mothers
mt's like these moms have got to be
stopped after you just praise them
turn against them
no more moms i'm the anti-milf
you're a milk mom's i'd like to kill
here comes the milkman that's like your
evil alter ego is the milkman
serial killer the milkman
okay so i'm so sorry i'm losing it okay
i will close the elevator doors on you i
will not wait for you i got places to be
this is my elevator boom bada boom
[Music]
you